[Musique]
cette exposition elle est assez
incroyable parce que d'abord elle est
vraiment inédite Patrick Deguine est
d'abord quelqu'un qui aimait Johnny
Hallyday qui faisait partie du fan club
et un jour Johnny a dit ok je veux bien
parce que c'est le fan club qui me
suivent sur deux tournées donc des
photos exclusives qu'on n'a jamais
exposé encore et pour la première fois
il y a plus de 50 clichés qui sont
exposés proposés aux vicinois
qu'il a accompagné pendant près de 20
ans de Johnny Hallyday dans toutes ces
dernières partie de carrière où il avait
vraiment un groupe rock n' roll et lui
est à l'harmonica je pense un des quatre
cinq meilleurs vraiment au monde
[Musique]
il va présenter son propre spectacle
donc c'est pas des reprises de Johnny
mais évidemment il y a des super clins
d'oeil parce que sur scène il partageait
des morceaux comme Gabriel d'une manière
incroyable
vers 11h madame le Maire les officiers
entre guillemets et puis les les gens de
voisins plus les fans vont être réunies
pour pour l'inauguration officielle de
cette exposition je crois même qu'il y a
une association de la ville qui fait de
la danse country qui va venir danser sur
du johnny c'est extraordinaire on a
réuni une vingtaine d'arlers des
voitures américaines pour que le décor
soit à la hauteur évidemment un déjeuner
à l'extérieur avec dans le style
américain burger frites etc sous des
tentes ça va être sympa on va être 150 à
déjeuner
le fan club de Johnny c'était de son
vivant le lien entre lui et le public et
malheureusement depuis sa disparition on
a un devoir de de de que cette légende
continue de vivre et on est là pour ça
[Musique]